hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and as i've often said on uh
podcast and elsewhere cosmology is a
great science because the universe is so
simple
it has ingredients in it right our
universe has electrons and atoms and
photons and neutrinos dark matter dark
energy but it's a fairly finite list
right it's not like there's a hundred
different ingredients that really matter
for the evolution of the universe and
even better when you look on
sufficiently large scales the universe
looks smooth if you kind of squint and
average out over a scale of i don't know
100 million light years across
it's more or less the same amount of
stuff in every part of the universe the
same number of galaxies and stars and so
forth and that helps us we can put
together a picture of what the universe
is doing how old it is etc
but then of course if you squint a
little bit closer
if you zoom in on what the universe is
doing all that simplicity kind of
evaporates and you see a very rich
complicated universe there are stars and
planets galaxies clusters of galaxies
filaments of galaxies and what have you
and then the particular way that these
structures both exist today and have
evolved over time
depends on the list of ingredients and
the expansion history of the universe
and so forth so the bread and butter of
modern cosmology is not measuring the
expansion rate or the acceleration rate
those are important things we do them
and they matter but most of
observational cosmology and theoretical
analytic cosmology is interested in the
structures that are there in the
universe so that's what we're going to
be talking about today with uh today's
guest is priya natarajan who is an
astrophysicist at yale and the author of
a book called mapping the heavens the
radical scientific ideas that reveal the
cosmos which traces both through the
history of mapping the heavens but also
the modern version of it and that's what
i'll be talking about mapping where the
galaxies are how they get distributed
and in particular priya is an expert on
gravitational lensing as a technique to
study structure in the universe einstein
predicted a long time ago that
gravitational fields will bend light and
we can use the amount of bending on
cosmological scales to figure out
exactly how much stuff there is
in the universe whether or not we can
see it this is obviously hugely
important for figuring out properties of
dark matter and more than that so we get
into some details on modern cosmology
and another thing that this is a
wonderful discussion for is the fact
that it really involves so many of the
different moving parts of modern science
more generally there are of course
observers collecting data there are
theorists proposing models but in modern
cosmology it also really matters that we
have simulations that we have
large-scale computer programs that are
trying to bridge the gap between the
theoretical ideas and the observations
of the data and finally
not to neglect them we have human beings
we have the fact that human beings
respond differently to different
scientific results and are predisposed
in different ways to different kinds of
scientific theories so pre and i talk
about that the existence of anomalies
despite the fact we have a really really
successful cosmological model no model
is perfectly successful so where are the
gaps where are the weak points which
might lead us to a better model in the
future this will bring you up to date on
what cosmologists are thinking about
right now and what to look for as we
learn more stuff in the future so let's
go
[Music]
priyanoto rajan welcome to the mindscape
podcast delighted to be here
so we're going to talk about cosmology
and i'm going to take for granted i'm
going to assume the audience knows that
the universe is big and that it's
expanding that it's full of galaxies
that are mostly smoothly distributed and
that the interesting part comes when we
say but it's not perfectly smoothly
distributed so you know as a working
cosmologist at the interface of data and
theory uh explain to us how you think
about the large-scale structure of the
universe like what are the basic facts
that the person out there should have in
mind while we have this conversation
i think you sort of outline sort of you
know the basic picture we need to have
you can just think of the universe as
expanding and with its entire contents
like not just expanding but you know the
expansion is accelerating
and that it is filled with a bizarre
kind of matter dark matter which is
nothing that we are familiar with
nothing on the periodic table some
likely exotic particle made in the early
universe
and that much of the action in the
universe uh starts kind of late like
relevant to us that is you know the
assembly of ordinary atoms kind of
happens a little late and i'm
particularly interested
in this sort of aggregation and clumping
of matter sort of a departure from the
simple kind of
linear
homogeneous kind of
distribution so early on we believe the
universe was more or less homogeneous
but that over time gravity which is the
most powerful
organizing force in the universe
collects
aggregates mass and matter both dark and
baryonic ordinary matter feel gravity
because we believe this dark matter is
actually a particle
and so then they aggregate they kind of
co-evolve in fact the dark matter is
sort of a cocoon in which ordinary
matter falls in you can really think of
it as like a cradle and you know cocoon
and um gas basically
you know uh for us
all of matter essentially in the
universe is kind of hydrogen really
we're really talking about hydrogen
it's all gas gas falls in cools
condenses forms stars and then you know
stars evolve
and i think there are many intriguing
mysteries that have to do with
the first set of stars that formed so
the onset how did it all get started we
kind of know how you know how the
universe itself got started you know
from a very hot dense state
but i think there are many more open
questions as the universe kind of
expanded cooled down and then these dark
matter cocoons
lit up for the first time so you know
the properties of the first stars well
actually i mean that makes me that leads
me to a question because i think this is
something that is
often glossed over in the details but we
have ordinary matter which is like you
say everything the periodic table
everything we've ever found here on
earth dark matter is something new
something different and we'll talk about
why we think that's there in a second
but
uh there's more dark matter than
ordinary matter but also
let's just get straight
what form the ordinary matter is in you
said mostly hydrogen and
so what what fraction of it is like
stars and planets versus what fraction
of it is just out there as gas in the
between the stars and planets
yeah so much of this hydrogen is
actually captured in stars
and planets and uh some of it a small
portion of it is kind of smeared
everywhere as material in between uh
galaxies in space and you know dark
matter is distributed similarly in the
sense that you know there's dark matter
is there everywhere in the universe very
lightly smeared
and then there are places pockets where
structure forms and when i what i mean
by structure is galaxies the visible
part sort of forms
and in those regions you have a
concentration of dark matter
and so and sort of you know light really
traces
um
dark matter which is why you know the
regions where you have an aggregation of
dark matter you also tend to have an
aggregation of ordinary matter can i ask
you because back in my day when i was in
graduate school
before we had really mapped out the
cosmic microwave background radiation
which you should tell us about but but
just to set the stage we didn't know
how structure grew there was this theory
that there were tiny fluctuations in the
early universe that grew over time but
there was a competing theory that there
were seeds like cosmic strings or
something else that sort of stirred up
the universe all along and
i get the feeling in fact i know for
sure but the audience doesn't know that
we more or less discarded this cosmic
string theory in favor of the primordial
theory is that right
yeah absolutely
and i think the compelling um evidence
for this idea of dark matter sort of you
know cold dark matter very sluggish
material particles constituting uh the
universe i should note here sluggish you
know everything is relative to the speed
of light right so these are super slow
compared to the speed of light um so the
theory in which all of the structure
that we see
is formed from the gravitational sort of
amplification of these little
inhomogeneities so you know you have
these little piles it's almost like you
know little piles of sand
and then because you already have a
little excess in one region you tend to
attract more because of gravity and you
sort of amplify and you grow masses in
sort of clumps
and this theory has been ratified and i
would say that you know it's called the
standard cold dark matter paradigm
it's been ratified and probably the most
powerful cosmological probe it has been
the cosmic microwave background
radiation so this is the relic radiation
uh hot radiation from the big bang
universe was at a very
dense hot sort of violent beginning
and so this is radiation that comes to
us when the universe was about 400 000
years old
and this is the last sort of direct
signal that we get from farthest back in
the universe
and i think what's remarkable about this
signal is not only does it sort of
telegraph
properties of the early universe
but cause
light that is coming to us from that
surface if you will
and it takes um it takes a finite time
for things because the speed of light
large as it is is still finite so this
light encounters the unfolding cosmic
saga of all the formation of galaxies
you know the first stars the first black
holes then the bigger galaxy's
assembling so this light encounters
everything and it carries an imprint
and i think that is the triumph of this
model so this model was not only able to
explain
what we see but the evolution over time
and also calculated was able to quantify
you know what imprints what are the
imprints you would see on the cosmic
microwave background
and all of those imprints have been now
detected and so that really basically
was
nail
secure nails in the coffin of alternate
theories right and you know i think this
theory is
very secure partly because there are
many independent lines of evidence and
this is one you know then there's the
properties of galaxies you know how they
cluster
and when they form
properties of other structures in the
universe like the ones that i
work on called clusters of galaxies
which are sort of larger assemblages
aggregates of about thousands of
galaxies held together again all by the
gravity of dark matter as it turns out
so i think that this theory um has
really emerged as
um you know sort of a v theory although
it is contested and you know i hope we
get a chance to talk later on about
how we are kind of stress testing this
model because the data has gotten so
much better
that we can really hone in on the very
detailed predictions
and challenge them with um uh with
observations yeah and that's going to be
the exciting thing is sort of looking
for places where the theory doesn't
quite match the data but let's just be
super duper clear here because out there
on the internet you can read all sorts
of things and i think you already said
this but maybe to emphasize it we're not
we're not really open for speculation
about the whole big bang expanding
universe model being wrong right we're
looking for tiny little variations
absolutely and you know i think that
you're absolutely right that you know it
bears a repetition
that you know this this idea of a hot
dense beginning the big bang and the
sort of subsequent description that
we've been talking about about sm that
is
very very securely settled you know as i
said you know many independent lines of
evidence and you know in a way one of
that's why it's been really hard to
falsify this theory too or to come up
with an alternative so there are you
know there are researchers working on
sort of an alternate theory partly
because you know beautiful as this
theory is and concordance with data
you know there's a couple of big nagging
questions you know first is this nature
of dark matter you know several decades
on
with searches directly looking for the
particle looking indirectly for a
signature of the particle they've all
come up empty
so we are yet to find this dark matter
particle
and second the universe is not just
expanding but the expansion is
accelerating and as we all know from our
experience of driving around you kind of
need to
you know hit the gas pedal if you want
to start accelerating right so clearly
something
we don't know what it is and so we've
called it dark energy is propelling the
accelerating expansion of the universe
so these two key elements and in terms
of the overall composition of the
universe these are the principal
components of the universe in terms of
you know the energy contribution to
overall energy contribution
and so it's embarrassing right so and
the stuff that we are made of that we
know quite well and we've chartered is
about four percent of the total
inventory so given that you have we have
these two big gaps there's obviously
room right now however wonderful this
theory is you know we really don't have
an understanding of what dark energy
really is
and so there are there is one sort of
alternative attempt to try to explain um
you know is there a theory in which you
could just modify the nature of gravity
somehow so that you can sort of do away
with the idea of dark matter and that
what you really have done is altered how
the force of gravity acts over large
distances
i mean i think it's an interesting
avenue worth exploring i mean i'm a
scientist i have to be open-minded
although i you know and this model the
cold dark matter model
um i have to say uh one of the reasons
it's very hard to falsify in addition to
um the overwhelming amount of
accumulated evidence
is the fact that is the history of how
this theory uh evolved itself and how
our understanding evolved
so in many ways it was a theory that
started out with degrees of freedom and
as we made observations you know you
hone and refine a theory so this theory
has been honed and refined for several
decades right when you say this theories
tell us exactly which of the many
theories that we're talking about you
mean it's the cold dark matter cold dark
matter standard theory okay
standard and when you say cold dark
matter theory that means not just
that there is cold dark matter but that
the universe is expanding and the cold
dark matter has been responsible for the
growth of galaxies and structure like
that's the whole theory that we're
talking about yeah that the whole
monopoly of you know how the universe
has started and evolved to be where it
is all of those elements form but i mean
we refer to it shorthand as cold dark
matter because
you know we see post-facto that cold
dark matter is in the driving seat
that's what has driven everything that
we really see but the people out there
listening might think you're talking
about you know what the dark matter
particle is but this what we when we use
the phrase the cold dark matter model we
mean this whole picture of cosmological
evolution yeah
science isn't about multiplying and
dividing or memorizing the name of the
planets or the species it's about
thinking and problem solving and taking
a critical attitude toward the world and
at the practical level according to the
department of commerce most jobs are
growing at the rate of four percent per
year while stem jobs were going at 27
with id tech the world leader in stem
education your kids will explore science
tech engineering and math topics that
are not covered in school as they are
prepared for a future that demands
literacy in these crucial fields right
now id tech is offering a great deal you
can save a hundred and fifty dollars on
weekly small group semesters or get
started with a one-on-one tutoring
session for just 49
go to
idtech.com mindscape right now and use
code mindscape to save 150 on weekly
small group semesters for a limited time
you can also get started with a 101
tutoring session for just forty nine
dollars that's code mindscape at id tech
dot com slash mindscape to save 150
dollars and your child can start
learning online from a live instructor
right now idtech.com
and so i mean maybe say a couple more
words because this dark matter versus
some alternative like modified gravity
is obviously a crucially important
question and i think like you say uh we
can imagine gravity being modified but
given all the evidence
for dark matter it's hard these days
especially with the microwave background
i think i think you know what is what
has been really difficult for these
alternate theories of gravity even
though they could dispel so you know
there's a lot of evidence
for the existence of dark matter sort of
halos of dark matter around every galaxy
pretty much in the universe
and that gets reflected the presence of
that dark matter gets reflected in the
motions of the stuff that we do see
which is stars because the stars are now
feeling the gravity of the whole galaxy
and so they're moving around much faster
than if they would be moving if only
gravity was provided by the visible gas
dust stars that we see so sort of the
original way in which you know vera
rubin and her collaborators came up with
the idea of dark matter in the first
place
and so you know to explain the so these
are called you know the motions of stars
that you map in galaxies it's called the
rotation curve basically you know how
the motion of these stars and so the
evidence for cold dark matter compelling
evidence came from sort of these
rotation curves where basically the
instead of seeing an edge to the galaxy
when light just drops off so you see
galaxies are very centrally concentrated
light in stars and then they become
fuzzy fuzzy fuzzy they appear to kind of
have an edge at least in light but it
turns out that if you actually look at
the motions of stars it doesn't look
like they have an edge looks like
actually there's something holding up
galaxies at the outer parts
and so that's reflected in this rotation
curve so these alternate theories can
actually kind of dispense this idea of
dark matter holding things up and they
can explain that
however the one effect that has not that
has evaded calculation for them
but um you know and they have been
attempts
is the bending of light
that um einstein's theory of general
relativity
predicts and is observed uh in abundance
in the universe so just that kind of
phenomenology of seeing light bending
and this is manifest this light bending
is manifest very clearly you see really
misshapen galaxies you see them kind of
stretched out like very unusual shapes
in very particular configurations
and that theory cannot quite
the calculation hasn't been done uh to
be fair but i think
that's you know one of the reasons the
fact that you have all this compelling
light bending that you see which is
information rich right i mean that's one
of the areas that i work in and you know
there is uh
so much data that shows you that there's
sort of rampant light bending
that that theory has not had um you know
well we'll see right in a few years i
mean i remain
um open-minded to see well you know this
is how we have to be a scientist right
as you know sean we're trained to stay
nimble
and sort of the provisional nature of
science sort of inherently provisional
nature of science is any at any time
it's you know best to date
you your understanding is best to date
and you have to remain open to revisions
and refinements well and also let me
just add in the
flux temperature fluctuations in the
microwave background radiation as yet
another piece of data that fits very
comfortably with dark matter and is very
hard to explain by modifying gravity
yeah so they have current versions of
their theory that can account for
you know the imprint in the cosmic
microwave background
uh but yeah it's not easy uh but as for
the cold dark matter model
it's a very nice fit and you know all
the details that we see so we see this
imprint in terms of wiggles in this
background radiation so this imprint
imprinted wiggles and you know the
wiggles are really small fluctuations in
the temperature like the sixth or
seventh decimal place right so
and but those details those very fine
details are just exquisitely explained
by the cold dark matter theory and just
to get on the table you know my vested
interest is very much in that uh
modified gravity should be the answer
not dark matter i would much prefer if
gravity were modified that'd be much
cooler for me but the data are not
letting me believe that
yeah not not right now anyway and not
this version right so it may turn out
that there is a version of a theory i
don't know that one of the reasons i
remain open-minded uh although i'm kind
of you know obviously my work is very
invested in the cold dark matter model
right
is the fact that you know we know that
einstein's theory is incomplete right
because um we believe that all the
forces do have to be unified so this is
not the last word on gravity
it's a compelling word on gravity so
einstein's theory has been tested in
many many regimes and it comes out tops
i mean it really comes out really fine
but
you know you never know um what may be
lurking there in terms of some tiny gap
or mismatch i mean this brings it brings
us to my favorite kind of uh you know
angle
my angle is that it is i mean for my
entire career one of the things that's
really driven me is to find these
potential
tiny gaps between you know theory and
data
because
um i think that there is a lot of
information and potential for discovery
in these gaps but you know not all gaps
right so obviously right there's sort of
the standard case from the history of
science where
urbane la verrier was very clever and he
looked at the you know the perturbations
in the orbit of uranus
and he was able to cleverly predict that
you know there's neptune that was
causing these perturbations
so you know everyone was worried right
because at the time because you know
newton's theories were laws were
sacrosanct and yeah here's a little
deviation but he was able to sort of you
know explain it away within the context
so newton's laws remain intact and
similarly there were anomalous um
anomalous uh precession in the orbit of
mercury and you know uh economical as
urban level uh la verrier was he said
hey same explanation i think there's
another planet somewhere between the sun
and mercury and he called it vulcan and
people went around looking for it and so
on
it's not there obviously and the
resolution to that required a brand new
theory right so it kind of although
einstein didn't set out to start
explaining that anomaly his theory
naturally explains that in his complete
reimagining of gravity itself right the
nature of gravity
so i think the gaps
are very enticing because you never know
right and one of the one of the great
things that einstein bequeathed to us
was this idea of the bending of light of
gravitational lensing which is where you
know you've already mentioned it but i
really wanted to dig into the details
about that for this discussion because
it's what you work on and it's kind of
something that doesn't get quite as much
popular discussion as maybe it could so
i think we can all intuitively see how a
big massive gravitational field could
deflect light that seems to make sense
but one of the great questions in
cosmology is do you see a galaxy an
image of a galaxy or the microwave
background i suppose you see something
out there in the sky
and you're saying well it's light has
been deflected
how do you know that like compared to
what how do you know what it should have
been if there weren't any gravitational
lensing
right uh thankfully for us most of the
universe
as we mentioned earlier on in our
conversation dark matter
you know is very lightly smeared so most
of the universe is kind of empty of
matter and there but however there are
regions where it's really concentrated
so when we look out into the night sky
you know the places where you would get
dramatic light bending the fraction the
patches on the night sky where you could
expect extreme distortion
probably 10
max
so most of the time when you're looking
at the universe you're not seeing
dramatic distortions
slight distortion perhaps so when you
look through regions where there aren't
large clumps of matter mostly dark
matter um then you know that um you are
not seeing uh you're seeing the
undistorted shapes of galaxies so yeah
this is a big tricky issue because you
know galaxies are born with a range of
native shapes yeah we need to know the
distribution of native shapes for
galaxies or birth shapes and then mod
you know that we see something that is
distorted so it is with respect to this
distribution so it's done statistically
that you know you have the uh a
distribution of the undistorted
birth shapes of galaxies and then you
look at a patch of the universe where
you know there is something like a
cluster of galaxies because you see all
the galaxies that are clustered together
to make that cluster and you know this
it's a huge repository of dark matter
and then you go measure the shapes of
galaxies behind this lens so this matter
acts as a lens very much like our
intuition with glass lenses and optical
lenses and so we're looking at a patch
of the universe in the back and the
light from there gets really highly
distorted we can then look at the
distorted shapes you get from
the stuff behind the lump versus the
rest of the universe and that is what
gives us a calibration we are able to
then back out
how much matter there should have been
in this sort of entire cylinder from us
from our eyes
all the way to where these galaxies
distant galaxies are so what we are able
to do is to sort of kind of invert the
distortion like we can undo the
distortions and figure out how much
matter you needed to produce that and in
fact it turns out this is one of the
most compelling
pieces of evidence for the existence of
vast amounts of dark matter because when
you go and back out and you look at a
region that has for example a cluster of
galaxies you know you're able to see all
the light so you can count up all the
galaxies the visible matter that is part
of this inferred amount of mass that you
need to produce the lensing and you see
it's a deficit of about a factor of 10.
so you need almost 10 times more matter
than you actually see in stars
and particularly um we now know that
clusters of galaxies
are the regions of the universe that are
sort of the largest uh contain the
largest amounts of dark matter
are most galaxies in clusters
no very small fraction of galaxies are
actually bound in clusters most of most
galaxies live a quiet life
in the field uh clusters i say so
because clusters are very violent
environments are very harsh environments
because you know their things are
whizzing around um galaxies are falling
in the gravity is so strong that they're
getting ripped apart when they fall in
so it's a very dynamic transformative
environment is is our galaxy the milky
way inside a cluster
no uh thankfully i guess for us
so it turns out the way structure is
organized in the universe is kind of
hierarchical by mass so there's like
small lumps medium lumps big lumps so
our galaxy is part of one of these sort
of medium mesh lumps which is called a
group
so we are part of something that's
called the local group
and uh
but you know so it's more than so it's a
few galaxies that are kind of hanging
out together
okay so even the lonely galaxies if
they're big enough we'll have like
little satellite galaxies and you know
we have a friend in andromeda but
otherwise it's not a very big collection
is that right that's right okay
well they're very faint they're lots of
faint galaxies that are part of our
local group and do they also by the way
have dark matter i mean isn't that a uh
if it were
modified gravity then i would think that
there'd be a sort of unbreakable
relationship between how much visible or
ordinary matter there was and the
gravitational field whereas if it's a
combination of dark matter invisible
matter then you might have mixtures
where sometimes it's all dark matter
very little visible and sometimes it's
the other way around
yeah
that's a great question so as it turns
out in our universe in this normal
sequence of how galaxies form assemble
and evolve over cosmic time
you actually find that the fraction of
dark matter that a galaxy should have is
a huge range
there's a lot of stochasticity so you
can have some galaxies that are quite
bereft of dark matter and then you can
have some extremely dark matter uh rich
galaxies
and so there's a real range that is
allowed and you know you can imagine uh
that you know you can see probably how
that happens because there's a there's a
lot of randomness in terms of physics
and dynamics of things getting close to
each other two galaxies smashing in
having a close encounter modifying each
other along the way so you can imagine
that there's a lot of room for variation
um
good and let's go back to the i i want
to dig in even more to the gravitational
lensing story so if i
understood correctly what you're saying
we can sort of look at
regions of the universe where we think
there's not a lot of stuff in the
foreground nearby and so we can see the
the galaxies far away
and of course the specific image of
those galaxies is not going to be
duplicated somewhere else but the
statistical features of that image you
know how many galaxies how close they
are etc and so then we can go and
compare where there is a cluster of
galaxies there will also be galaxies in
the background we know because we can
look at their redshifts and we can
compare their statistics is that what we
do that's right we compare their shapes
their shapes we literally just compare
their shapes
um and look at how distorts we we plot
out the distribution of shapes and you
see how wide that distribution is but
there's something even cooler though so
in parts of the universe like clusters
where you know i'm sort of repeatedly
saying right i mean this is the joke
about people like me who work on
clusters like every grant proposal
starts out with clusters are the largest
repositories of dark matter in the
universe yeah and anyway so in clusters
the inner regions of clusters there's a
huge amount of dark matter and the light
bending is proportional to how
concentrated the dark matter is
how
closely packed it is right so the inner
parts of clusters are so closely packed
that the light bending is so extreme
that you can think of light i mean i
find this analogy useful look i mean the
thing with analogies is they stop
working at some point
they let you get to a point so you can
think of light as a tube the bending is
so extreme kind of close in to the sort
of concentrated part of a cluster for
example or even a galaxy so that you
know there are galaxies that have huge
amounts of dark matter in the center
that you can think of this tube of light
cleaving into two
so basically what happens is you end up
seeing multiple images of the same
single object so in reality there's only
one object but you see multiple copies
of its image
and you and there are very specific
configurations that you know you can
look at those configurations and you can
figure out ah this one has split
but you can do something even better
right because every galaxy in the
universe has its unique fingerprint the
way we know these are multiple copies of
the same object is they have the same
spectra you can go and take the spectrum
and they're identical right
so you know that this is in fact just an
artifact in the sense that it's a
multiple image of an individual source
and you know and this multiple imaging
of how dramatic it can be you know
really depends on the concentration of
dark matter right so you can split
so you so there's a curious thing that
happens right so you split you have an
you have an uh distant faint galaxy one
other thing the lensing does it kind of
magnifies because it changes the surface
area you can think of the tube
starting out as a small tube and then
becoming thicker if you will so the
surface area changes so you actually
magnify and you bring things into view
so that's why it's a lens you bring
things into view
and you see these faint objects that you
wouldn't otherwise see so not only do
you magnify them you can multiply image
them you split them up but then you
produce two for example so classic
classic splitting is you have two very
bright images and you have one d
magnified image in the center sure you
actually produce an odd number of images
so you have three five seven and we've
actually seen all of these
configurations now with the hubble space
telescope and verified that they are
copies of each other by taking their
spectra
i mean you mentioned the space telescope
which is good because i wanted to sort
of take a little side light onto
the data and where we get it from so uh
the space telescope is one place but i
presume there are other places and also
talk a little bit about the ecosystem of
who is observing
who builds a telescope who are the
theorists who analyze the data because
you're not out there with your eyeball
to the end of the telescope collecting
data right
right no i'm not and in fact sadly now
almost nobody is looking through the
class literally right the people even
the observers are looking at computer
screens right um at this point but yeah
so i think the uh sort of the the sort
of ecosystem of how all of this work
gets done is that you know you have
these skilled teams of people with
different kinds of technical expertise
so you have the observers you have the
instrument builders who built the
spectrographs there are and the light
buckets so ground-based telescopes space
telescopes are actually collecting all
the data then you have people who
skillfully reduce this data you know
remove all the noise from the signal and
then they
there are people like me who then
model who have theoretical ideas
theoretical uh pictures and story lines
and we build our models in such a way at
least that's the aspiration we build
models that can be directly confronted
with the data
so and then you have people who are
actually doing computer simulation so
they're basically doing computer models
of the evolution of structure in this
sort of cold dark matter paradigm or any
sort of you know they can change the
initial conditions they can play with
the kind of dark matter particle so
these are just sort of you know our sort
of cosmology where we can't perform
controlled experiments these are our
proxy experiments right so then you have
the simulator so then you have these
sort of
interpolating people like me so i
analyze simulations
and then i build a theoretical model i
build a conceptual model that can
connect the simulations enabling us to
mock and do observations in the
simulation then confront that with the
data and then infer what is going on i
mean when you say simulations what
exactly
are we simulating like a galaxy has 100
billion stars do we have like 100
billion
conceptual stars in a simulation or do
we include uh exploding stars and
magnetic fields what is the state of the
art there right the state of the art now
is quite remarkable but we are still not
at the level of we are we are simulating
aggregates of stars we are not yet
simulating individual stars
however we have clever techniques to
mimic the actual explosion of the star
because you know what really matters
about a supernova exploding is the
energy what is happening to that energy
how is it getting distributed and the
metals that are locked in in this old
star how they're getting expelled so
those are processes that you can mimic
without actually sort of you know
following the individual star and its
life cycle so you know we've abstracted
these out so
there are simulations are done on
multiple scales the kind that i was
talking about are simulations
cosmological simulations in which we
sort of have a sort of a grander we want
a grander view so we want to see
a piece a small chunk of the universe
with all the stars in galaxies locked in
and the dark matter and we want to see
sort of the co-evolution and now we can
even drop in particles that would behave
like black holes
and we can see how the whole because we
know you know we know all the
ingredients in the universe so you just
pop them all in
uh abstract their behavior depending on
what we are interested in and then we
can look at the evolution turn the clock
on and we can look at the evolution of
these components a combined evolution
which is very hard to do theoretically
you know it's very hard to do because
it's all the non-linearities and how
think things couple on small scales and
so on that you can't capture with sort
of you know theoretical models however
abstract they are and so on and then
there are simulations where people zoom
in so there are these simulations called
you know general relativistic magneto
hydrodynamic simulations so these are
simulations where you zoom right into
the heart of a galaxy you focus on the
black hole you focus on the gas flows
around the black hole and you know and
then you put in you have magnetic fields
that are threading it and so on
so you know we can abstract away
portions of problems and focus and
numerically tackle them
and i think you know this is one of the
exciting challenges that has also kind
of informed the arc of my work which is
how do you bridge the scales how do you
take a simulation that looks at just the
inner part and then a simulation that
looks at a much larger scale how do you
put them together how do you piece them
together
in terms of the implications in terms of
you know the astrophysical phenomena
motions of particles you know are there
being
flows kind of pushed out to large radii
how do you couple them so yes
simulations have been very powerful in
cosmology they've been transformative in
cosmology well and just to emphasize the
extent to which we've made progress you
know like back in my graduate school
days that were formative for me
all the simulations had just dark matter
in them right because we figured well
most of the matter is dark and it's easy
to do they don't even collide just
putting in ordinary matter where you
could make stars etc
that was a big step and and the state of
the art has has come a long way even
though we're not done yet we still have
a long way to go and get even better
yeah absolutely
and
you mentioned a little bit about the
black holes at the centers of galaxies
and this is another place i think that
maybe you know some uh some
comparisons are are useful because i
think a lot of people think well there's
a supermassive black hole the center of
a galaxy which is a statement many
people have heard isn't that where most
of the gravity in that galaxy is coming
from but that's nowhere near right
absolutely even though uh the black hole
um has all these bizarre properties it
turns out in terms of the mass budget of
the overall galaxy it's kind of teeny
weeny it's you know maybe um you know
even a millionth you know of the total
mass including so for example the total
mass of the milky way is 10 to the 12
times the mass of the sun and the mass
of the black hole is four million times
so it's like 10 to the sixth quarters of
magnitude right there's six orders of
magnitude difference right
so but they punch more than their weight
because they have these bizarre
properties
and they sit uh in the centers of
galaxies
it turns out you could have some of them
wandering around too i mean that's some
you know exciting new work that um uh we
recently published that you could have a
population of kind of wandering black
holes but regardless they um there's
only a very small region around the
center of the galaxy where the
gravitational effect of just the black
hole dominates the stars take over very
quickly
so there's a small region of influence
and basically outside that it's
gravitationally inconsequential but we
now know you know so we we had dismissed
them right we thought okay they're
really tiny they're important right
around if you're right there of course
it's consequential but otherwise not
but it turns out now they were believed
to be so marginal but now we've
understood
that they actually play an outsized role
in modulating how stars form
stars appear to form inside out in
galaxies by and large so the inner
regions are where bulk of the stars are
forming and so black holes are sitting
there so it turns out that black holes
can heat the gas
and they can you know the energy that is
falling into the black hole is a gas
particle that is getting gobbled by the
black hole
gets pulled in gets heated up gets fed
up starts to radiate and gives out a lot
of heat
that heat can prevent stars from forming
because you know for forming stars you
need to cool the gas
so this is actually adding energy so we
realized suddenly that black holes could
be sources of energy in galaxies and
therefore the sort of intricate sort of
feedback between how they either do they
promote or do they prevent stars from
forming this whole cycle has been
much better understood recently and now
we believe that even though
gravitationally they're not as important
they punch much more than their weight
in terms of determining you know the
phenomenology of a guy how it looks
because the how it looks is determined
by the stars so and how many stars form
so it modulates we believe the
efficiency of formation one thing that
is coming clear from what you're saying
is that uh
you know again the
whole scale of time and space in
cosmology is so different than what we
are used to in our everyday lives right
it's been 14 billion years since the big
bang we look at pictures of galaxies and
they're not moving they're just sitting
there right like when we take a picture
of them but
on the scale of let's say one billion
years
a lot happens in the universe the
universe is actually a really dynamic
place even on the scales of galaxies and
clusters
yeah absolutely
you know it is it's um
one sort of analogy that you know i can
think of um is that you know when you
look at um an ant hill from really far
away you don't see all the little ants
kind of busily walking around you know
it seems to be a pretty stable structure
that keeps its shape and stuff when
you're looking from when you get close
you see oh wow look at the amount of
activity these ants are you know up to
so it's somewhat like that right so it's
a question of scale and perspective so
if
as you said a billion years is uh it's a
fraction of the age of the universe and
still so for example you know when two
galaxies crash into each other sort of
the finale you know of them ending up as
one sort of mixed up messed up product
of soup of stars and gas could take a
billion years right that whole process
right that's our future right we're
going to crash into andromeda
yes yes and
you know we would
make uh milkamera as it's called right i
did not know that but i i've often asked
about this and you know people appear
somewhat like worried and then i have to
say well you know we're talking of
billions of years in the future also
come on come on folks
i think uh we need to pay attention here
and now right like we seem to be on
course to destroy our planet within the
next couple of hundred years so it's the
galaxy's merging that i'm really worried
about yeah right exactly so i mean let's
get back to these black holes does every
galaxy have a massive black hole at the
center
it appears so it looks like um it is
such an essential and fundamental
feature of how structure forms
just as you know stars form in this
cocoon of dark matter it appears that
the formation of a black hole
is pretty fundamental so
most if not all galaxies
appear to have a black hole in its
center and in the cases where we don't
see one we see signatures of it having
been kicked out so it might have been
there might have crashed into something
and then it got kicked out so there are
a few cases where we see that kind of
signature and what is the story of where
these black holes came from were they
there for a long time or did they slowly
accumulate
so um you know this is another thread
of work of my research which is trying
to understand the origin of the first
black holes so one thing we know there's
a natural way to form black holes which
is just the end states of stars so if
you're a star that is you know eight
times or so more massive than the sun
when you are born
inevitably you finish your life cycle
you you know all the fuel gets exhausted
and then you leave behind a black hole
but those black holes are really really
tiny and the black hole in the center of
our galaxy is you know four million
times the mass of the sun this one is
perhaps a few times the mass of the sun
so how do you grow from
what are the intermediate what do the
teenage years look like what does
adulthood look like for little black
holes so it turns out that black holes
can grow either by accretion of matters
which is sucking in matter accretion and
fancy way of saying sucking in matter
or by crashing into each other so when
they obviously merge into each other
they shake up all of space-time they
produce gravitational waves we've seen
that happening for little black holes
we've not seen that happening yet for
supermassive black holes but that's
coming with the lisa interferometer in
space that is going to be put up in
within 20 years or so
so we know that you know um black holes
can grow in these sort of two different
ways
but there is an interesting conundrum
that kind of motivated a lot of my work
more than oh gosh i hate to admit it
about 15 years ago
because it reminds me of how old i am
when i think about oh my god that paper
was 2005.
um is you know so we also know that
these growing kind of feeding black
holes are quasars and these are very
bright beacons that we can see so this a
quasar is basically the heart the black
hole at the heart of a galaxy that is
feeding so rapidly that it outshines the
entire galaxy and we see them you know
peppered everywhere in the they're
really peppered they're not all that
common they are rare objects
but um the the ones that are lit so
black holes themselves are actually
fairly common but not all of them are
actively feeding and growing so for
example the black hole the center of our
galaxy is actually fasting i mean you
really won't see it it's not a quasar
but it used to be a quasar
part did it used to be a quasar did it
go through the face probably yeah it
probably cycled through so when you know
when food was ubiquitous it was a quasar
and then it depleted everything that it
could eat in its vicinity and in the
absence of having new gas getting
smashed into the center with the merger
they're sitting there you know fasting
so these feasting black holes use as
quasars and we are discovering and from
the brightness of those quasars you can
figure out how big the black hole is so
the bigger the black hole the more
rapidly voraciously it can feel a fuel
itself and feed and therefore the
brighter it will be i mean maybe we need
to be a little bit more specific about
how a black hole can be bright since
after all they're black
that's right so that
a black hole is bright because of the
dying gasps of the matter that are
actually getting eventually sucked into
oblivion by the black hole so on route
whatever the black hole is feeding on be
the star it could also
black holes can also gobble stars so but
if it basically matter coming in the
form of gas and you know as we said
early on right everything is basically
hydrogen right so hydrogen is glowing
and that's what you see so you and
that's how you see a black hole
and these quasars are basically where
you see very very um you know very
active feeding episodes and we are
detecting these quasars now to very
early on in the universe you know when
the universe was a fraction of its
current age 10
of its current age right and we are
already seeing quasars and once again
right we know where the quasars are
because we can measure their redshifts
so we know they're very distant
and they already seem to be harboring a
black hole that is a billion times the
mass of the sun well but you left us
hanging a little bit because you said
we know how to make a black hole from a
single star and it'd be a few times the
mass of the sun and you said that that
could grow by either creating random
matter in the universe or by coalescing
with other black holes so which is it or
is it both or i mean how do you go from
five to a million yeah it is both it's
both but it turns out that
it is a challenge to grow them
regardless okay
and you can you know they will grow as
long as they are very gluttonous for
periods of time so that they really
super actively feeding
then you can start from something that's
a few times mass of the sun to the guy
that's sitting in the center of art
actually the center of our galaxy like
you know a few million times you can
grow with just you know one or two
episodes of gluttony
but you know if you have something more
massive than that
then you know it starts to become really
problematic because then you have to
really be over feeding for a very
throughout your lifetime you have to be
overfeeding in order to end up and
that's hard because to over feed at that
rate you need a huge amount of gas
supply and we know that the gas supply
in the universe kind of drops with time
so which is why there's not much gas in
the center of our galaxy the most of the
gas by now is locked up in stars
there's fallen into the black
or it's fallen into the black hole
exactly it's already gone into black
holes or it's captured in stars so i
would think that you know a galaxy is a
big thing and has some extent and
there's stars all over the place so if
those stars the the more massive of them
exploding and creating black holes is
the origin of the supermassive ones i
would be mystified as to why the
supermassive ones are in the middle of
all these galaxies but there must be
some it's gravity again it's gravity in
action so
it's because it's
it's very massive it starts compared to
the stars right compared to the mass of
a star it's much more massive as it's
gathering mass as it's gathering mass it
slows down and it becomes you know
plumper and plumper and then it gets
settled down to the center so really
it's kind of it is this dynamical kind
of thing once again where it's not that
the center of the galaxy is some special
place where black holes form but any
black holes that are medium-sized would
sort of drift down there in a national
unnatural sort of segregation
yeah and and the segregation is quite
efficient because of the sort of mass
difference right black holes are so much
more massive than individual stars so
they can really grind past stars
and settle in but you know i was coming
i was talking about these right quizzes
at high redshift because
that kind of posed a problem that many
including me wanted to solve uh was
exciting because you see these billion
solar mass black holes in place
where the universe was a fraction of it
so you know you could not have
there's not enough time to grow from you
know a little you know few times the
mass of the sun two billion times the
mass of the sun within that short span
of time that is available in the early
universe you know there's you know this
this other fact about the passage and
the flow of time in the universe there's
not a whole lot of time in the universe
early on a lot of the time is actually
kind of stretches towards later times in
the universe
and so then it was pretty clear the
answer was obvious but the question was
what do we do how do we get this to
happen right obviously what you had to
do is you had to make seed black holes
that were really massive from the get go
so if you could make a seed black hole
somehow from the physics that is you
know ten thousand times the mass of the
sun hundred thousand times the masses
get go just from the get-go
then you have it then it's not a there's
no feeding problem then you know these
uh quasars that you see that are really
bright are very rare so you know it all
works out really nicely because you know
you need that to happen for the rare
cases but enough of the rare cases not
just a freak case but it's a population
right so we propose this idea of direct
collapse black hole so these are black
holes that form from gas that collapses
very rapidly you bypass the formation of
a traditional star okay you don't have
to cycle the gas through a star and then
you leave a little wimpy black hole but
in fact you put you know the analogy
that really works at least worked for me
when i was first doing the calculations
because it was really quite apt is you
know if you're sitting in a bathtub
i love to take baths so when you pull
the plug
you see that vortex the water rapidly
fueling down that is exactly what
happens with the gas that forms these
direct collapse black holes early on in
the universe so you literally what we
had to do is to find the analog of the
taking the plug out
and you know a region in the universe
where you could somehow
cause motions kind of you know could you
whip up some motions very early on in
the gas
you know and it turns out that there are
places in the universe this can happen
because in the sequence of how galaxies
and stars form you first form a huge
disk of gas
and then the
gas cools and fragments and form stars
so if you had this big
disc of gas and you prevented
fragmentation
and ended up creating a vortex that
could cycle all the and you can create a
vortex because you know you can set up
these sort of global kind of
disturbances in the gas that could set
up this vortex so you could instigate
this vortex um with known astrophysical
phenomena nothing you know uh nothing um
extraordinary
and then the only thing you have to make
sure is that it this gas disc does not
fragment before the stuff falls in if it
fragments it forms stars then you're
done then you don't you can't make this
big seed so we also know how to prevent
the fragmentation of gas how do you
prevent the gas from cooling
it's really neat in the early universe
you know you can just have to get rid of
molecular hydrogen so you know it's a
little bit on you know it's a detailed
physics but so basically you can form
these very massive black hole seeds and
that sort of alleviates this problem of
uh how these very big uh quasars bright
quasars with super massive black holes
or even ultra massive black holes are
already in place early on in the
universe but when you say from the
get-go already in place just to be clear
to our audience you don't mean from the
big bang the big bang was stolen oh no
there is a huge gap as we said right
there's not a whole lot happening in
terms of the assembly of structure
and you know there's a lot of um portion
of the age of the universes and you know
just radiation dominated then you move
on to sort of a matter dominated era but
only very
very towards the very end you know it's
very recently that we started assembling
galaxies so this is talking very much
relative to the assembly the epoch when
the first star is formed so it's around
about the same time and you know then
the question is could you form the
picture that i've given you it sounds
like you could form the black holes
before you make the stars oh okay yeah
because there's gas in there without
stars
to prevent the fragmentation you kind of
need some stars in place already at
other places you need a neighborhood
of stars little galaxies and then you
can have this gas disk make your vortex
and give you uh your direct class
because we talked about the dark ages in
between when the microwave background
came around between 400 000 years or so
uh and then the lighting up of the first
stars which was when do we know
yeah we we don't know quite precisely
there's a little bit of uncertainty uh
because we don't know exactly when the
first star likely formed but probably
you know about six
six to eight billion years ago
so yeah i'm thinking from the big bang
so if it's 14 billion year old yeah it's
still six to eight billion years works
either direction because it's a 14
billion year old universe yeah that's
very it's very good uh okay yeah so
that's a lot of dark ages actually right
and the final provocative thing that you
mentioned there is that you can have not
just supermassive black goals at the
centers of galaxies but ones that are
just wandering freely through the
universe that are not attached to
galaxies right
and you know that is something that you
know so one of the big pieces of the
puzzle right as we're talking about
these growth history of black holes is
that you know we are looking at the
infant black holes and then we look at
the geriatric ones and then so what's
happening in between so there's a phase
called intermediate mass black holes and
that's been pretty elusive it's like
it's almost like you know looking at a
population of people where you just
don't see the teenagers and you see
either the infants and little kids or
you see adults and older people right
so but they are there and like rebel
teenagers uh these intermediate mass
black holes are not actually where we
believe they might be lurking so it
turns out they are not in the centers
they are not massive enough to have sunk
into the centers we've been looking for
them
in fainter galaxies because you know how
big a black hole is is tied to the mass
of the stars that formed around it as we
saw earlier
and so we would have to look in sort of
wimpy galaxies to look for these sort of
wimpy or uh intermediate mass black
holes but we had very little success
finding them so then it turns out that
they were one was found and we found it
was not at the center it was far out so
that prompted us to start thinking about
you know in the simulations and so there
was a breakthrough with this simulation
that one of my collaborators and their
team did in which most simulations these
models you had to pin down the black
hole to the center of the galaxy just a
numerical technique you had to do that
and in this simulation they didn't have
to do that they just let it move freely
as it wants it settles down in the
center because that's sort of because of
its gravity dominating but it turns out
that in the process of galaxies kind of
merging and their black holes stumbling
around there are many that are left
wandering
in the outskirts of individual galaxies
and in clusters so we detected this
population and we've characterized and
that's sort of you know the uh exciting
new result but you know the one question
that you had earlier that sean i want to
come back to
um you know it was a great question you
asked about this sort of the standard
cold dark matter model right and the and
the sort of the tensions
and you know i want to um you know i'm
very excited about this so i want to
share this so recently remember sort of
this looking for gaps thing recently we
found something really intriguing
and that is that the strength of lensing
so now we are back to lensing away from
black holes still the dark universe
though still you know still the
invisible universe um that the strength
of lensing that is observed in the
universe
is incommensurate
with the expectations of the cold dark
matter model
for the sort of the inner parts of
galaxies right so you have a cluster you
have all these cluster galaxies that are
part of it all held together by dark
matter so there's like the smooth sea of
dark matter holding everything together
but then each galaxy has its own little
halo and you know content of dark matter
around it
and from the inside out so there's dark
matter everywhere in a galaxy so we find
that there are some new lensing signals
because there's deeper data so you could
look and you know capture
tinier lensing signals so even smaller
distortions on smaller scales the hubble
was able to detect it was a long look
and there we found that the strength of
lensing therefore the number of lensing
features all these strong distortions
doesn't match with the predictions of
cold dark matter theory
and the reason this is super intriguing
it's a gap so by a factor of 10 okay
it's huge sorry
a factor of 10 between what and what
what what is the thing we're measuring
the predictions of the number of these
kind of little lenses inside lenses
events that the cold dark matter theory
predicts from simulations uh versus the
real universe is providing for us so
it's a factor of 10 off so the real
universe
the lenses within lenses right so we
have this big lens and then you have
these galaxies that act as little lenses
they are much more efficient by a factor
of 10.
the universe is a much more efficient
lensing machine
than our cold dark matter theory
suggests
the reason i mean of course the
discrepancy by itself is awesome right
it's factor of 10. so you can't kind of
say well you know maybe you have a slop
or factor of two here maybe you have
something missing here
you can't unless of course you know you
have to conjure up like six different
things that are all you know factors of
1.5 to 2 and kind of really you know
knit them together to get you that so
the reason this is really intriguing is
previously you know so as i said you
know the gap finders are
around many of us are gap finders
previous gaps that were found actually
went in the opposite direction so the
real universe did not have as much
matter piled in the centers of galaxies
it appeared that there was less matter
piled in the centers of galaxies than
the theory would predict
and so here we are finding something
completely the opposite it's a different
environment and it's something that you
alluded to earlier right that you know
this is the dense this is the equivalent
yeah cluster is the equivalent of like
new york city like a bustling city
tightly packed densely packed
so you know the previous findings were
sort of in the suburbs right so in kind
of isolated galaxies or galaxies and
groups and so on so i mean this is um
you know in my opinion this is a very
intriguing mismatch and this is going to
be kind of hard to um
incorporate and argue away within the
cold dark matter model i mean it could
be that you know there's something
obviously it could be that you know the
simulations are after all you know we
are putting in what we are getting out
of the simulation so you know
computationally we may be missing some
feature maybe we are not modeling
something correctly but it's still
pretty hard to see how um
how it's such a big uh factor and if
it's such a big factor then it's kind of
puzzling why everything else kind of
fits so well i mean if you're so off
right like how does everything else fit
so well to be clear about you you just
made this point but just to super
clarify it when we talk about
a discrepancy between the theory and the
and the observations
um
the theory doesn't speak to us in an
unmediated way making that prediction is
a highly contentious thing and like you
say there's a lot of simulations
involved etcetera etcetera so
the
even if it's a small likelihood the
option remains open that the theory is
fine but we haven't correctly understood
what it predicts yeah absolutely spot on
because i mean what we are inferring
even from these simulations are mediated
by a model right so there is a model so
there's an intermediate stage so it
could be that there is something in our
sort of conceptual model but you know
there's of course the other exciting
possibility that maybe something
you know about one of our assumptions
about the nature
of the dark matter particle itself right
um
is not quite right i mean this is super
interesting it's speculative you know
and i'm not pushing that i mean i'm not
saying that you know we're calling the
entire paradigm into question or any
such thing it's just that it's very
interesting because you know these kinds
of stress tests
are exciting because once again you
never know if you're in the neptune
situation or the mercury situation right
that's right but so let's again put it
into context again you already did this
but this is such a rich story and it
goes back and forth so i want to make
sure we get it right um for a long time
now there has been a uh
or there was
it always seems to go away but there are
always these claims that cold dark
matter theory predicts too much
concentration on small scales that it
predicts that uh the centers of galaxies
should have more dark matter than we
observed there and there should be
more little uh satellite galaxies than
we observe but the issue always has been
that you're trying to compare theory and
observation with the dark matter theory
in a regime where it's not just the dark
matter that matters you're looking at
the regimes where the stars and the gas
and everything
are important and those are the hardest
things to model is that accurate so far
absolutely absolutely and these
discrepancies always seem to show up
in the uh parts of galaxies in the
regions of the universe
where
normal matter and dark matter are really
rubbing up against each other like
really closely packed
and we have made this assumption that
this dark matter does not interact with
the normal matter in any way other than
gravitationally so there's no charges
you know there's no electrical force
there's no other kind of force
and um and i think you know um
absolutely so that's really where all
the tensions uh are emerging
and um in the previous kind of crises uh
in the inner parts of galaxies so even
though
so one thing you could do right you can
imagine that if you need you could just
redistribute if you found a way to
redistribute matter so you have
suppose that you know in nature you
start out with you know the inner parts
of galaxies being really dominated by
dark matter but then somehow i don't
know supernova some
some explosions something happen that
pushes out some of the dark matter and
so evacuates it if you will right and
reduces the amount of so you know that
kind of
redistribution could work
but once again and that they believed
was really sort of what worked to
explain these things away when the
original finding was that dark matter
appears to be heaped much more strongly
compared to the real data
but i think the
the paradox is that now we are finding
with better data you know what has
really changed is much better data
um higher resolution data we're actually
finding that in the real universe it's
actually much more heaped in the centers
of galaxies that live in clusters right
okay it's a very specific environment
but again i just want to go through the
whole story very slowly because it does
go back and forth so the original
problems were that galaxies were
smoother in the center than the dark
matter theory seem to predict and you
know people will say well then why did
you cling to your dark matter theory why
don't you you know try to modify it and
you know you and i know well of course
people try to modify it that's full
employment i've written papers about you
know modifications of dark matter
particles interacting with each other
interacting with ordinary matter etc etc
my impression so i'm going to ask you as
the expert because i've not followed
this in recent decades
my impression is that largely those
attempts failed like it wasn't easy
to add new physics to dark matter to
explain these anomalies and on the other
hand you know the more this data
improved and the more the simulations
improve the anomalies did not tend to
stick around we we mostly
have accounted for them in in terms of
ordinary non-dark matter physics is that
fair right yeah yeah and the resolution
was found within the cold dark matter
theory and our methods of simulation
right okay within that constant context
of that theory absolutely right that you
know that the modifications the kind of
modifications that were suggested you
know self-interacting dark matter
self-annihilating dark matter all of
these options it turns out
were not really needed because once the
simulations improved and our
understanding of this physics the you
know the complex physics of you know
kind of normal matter and dark matter
kind of
being clumped in the inner regions and
their potential impacts on each other
sort of the sort of an interplay they
don't interact but there's an interplay
right and once we could simulate that
better those anomalies kind of went away
mostly went away right and so good but
the new one that you're pointing at does
it have a name is there a label for the
dna
ggs in good astronomy speak we have an
acronym okay an acronym that's not
particularly imaginative
uh but you know it's it's telegraphic it
contains uh uh information it's called
ggsl
galaxy galaxy strong lensing yeah you
need a better label for this i'm sorry
your branding team needs to get together
and really work on this okay galaxy
galaxy strong lensing and it's giving us
the opposite direction of an anomaly in
the sense that there's more structure on
these small scales but as you say
in the particular environment of
galaxies inside clusters yeah
that's right
which is why you know we are still
pushing really hard to find
there's a lot of room for finding
resolutions within cold dark matter
because these are complex places right
there's a lot happening yeah so i mean
this does seem to be again the kind of
environment that is the hardest for us
to understand so uh having an anomaly
maybe shouldn't be too surprising but
then your point is but this is such a
big anomaly we still got to pay
attention to it
right and that it goes in the opposite
direction i think crucially right that
it's you know it's big it's a factor of
10 but it also goes in the opposite
direction so i think this is the this is
the problem that i've been really
engaged with trying to see
if you could explain this away and
account for this factor of 10 mismatch
within the current theory like what
could i mean what could we be missing
you know what um process or whatever
could we be missing well but also it
does bring us into interesting
philosophy of science territory because
when you are faced with a discrepancy
you have lots of options right like one
is well your prediction isn't very good
your simulations weren't very good
another is your theory isn't very good
you need to understand the ordinary
matter more another is you need a better
theory um
and
and one of the things we don't often
like to admit as scientists but it's
certainly true is that we're more likely
to pay attention to anomalies that have
ready-made theoretical explanations
right when we discovered the
accelerating universe in 1998 part of
the reason why it was so rapidly
accepted was because albert einstein
gave us a solution to this problem back
in 1917 the cosmological constant so
inadvertently right he didn't want to do
it but he did it but we had an instant
theory that explained this so for your
anomaly for ggsl galaxy galaxy strong
lensing is there an easy theoretical
explanation that
actually involves the physics of dark
matter or something like that or is it
more likely to be found in
gastrophysics as we call it
you know i um i've got the fence about
this one uh in in terms of where i think
the the resolution uh might lie
i mean one can speculate right one
potential because it's such a particular
environment in a very specific set of
circumstances
um it could be that there's something
that we have there's some either
physical process that we missed
that operates much more efficiently in
these dense environments right um
and um
it could be that like it could be a
physical process that you're completely
missing or it could be that there's an
you know incorrect implementation of the
physics process in the simulation as you
said right and so you know i i have a
sort of a dark history as a sort of
historian slash philosopher of science i
started a phd which i didn't finish
uh but you know these are the kinds of
questions that motivated me then and
which have now you know uh caused me to
think much more deeply about what i do
so i was very interested in the role of
simulations right so what do what are
simulations doing so they are often
thought of as tools right as ways of
visualizing and a way of propagating
forward even from what i the kind of
description i gave you today when we
were talking is that well it allows you
to calculate the evolution of time over
time of a small chunk of the universe
all the complexity we can redo it you
know the big question is in the fields
like ours right where you can't perform
controlled experiments you know
simulations are actually
occupy a much more important uh place
because there is a way at least now we
are seeing like in this case right it
could well be
that there is something that we are
missing in the simulation right in which
case you know us and and this and we are
able to narrow it down and in which case
then you know the simulation would have
been generative
of a new discovery right and this is not
a role that we expect simulations to
have you know if you look at the oed
simulation the definition of simulation
right it's pretty dodgy so um
yeah um i think that it's very very
exciting to kind of come up against you
know um i don't have to uh you know it's
a real pleasure to be able to talk to
you someone like you who's thought about
this a lot you know the limits of
knowledge right the things you think
about a lot right what are the limits is
everything knowable uh what determines
um no ability
and um and i think um you know i should
come clean i mean i already you know as
you know scientists fall into camps i
mean
i believe there is no reason to think
that everything ought to be knowable
[Laughter]
all right you're allowed to think that i
think that uh my i'm very happy
to imagine that not everything is
knowable but i'm much more impressed
with how much we have figured out than
we have any right to be so i'm
suspicious that you know i'm not i don't
think we're at the boundaries or the the
limits of any of those things anytime
soon but i wanted to ask i mean since
we're past the hour mark of the of the
podcast this is where we let our hair
down a little bit um
what about the sociology of the
community in the face of anomalies like
this i mean i had adam reese on the
podcast we talked about the hubble
tension uh we've talked in different uh
places about different kinds of
contentious scientific issues and
you know i think that there is a
a tendency
among non-scientists to think of the
scientific community as much more
monolithic as it is either they're all
you know pushing the agenda of the
establishment or whatever or or they're
all
blown geniuses with their own theories
but really there's a lot of
heterogeneity right like when you have a
claim like this that there's an anomaly
we should be paying attention to
some people are going to be like oh yeah
we should pay attention to that others
like ah it'll go away
what is your feeling about the different
camps out there in the community yeah i
mean
it's so acutely sean unsurprisingly
right so i mean the community is really
quite um
heterogeneous in terms of their
attitudes
and uh and i think that there is a large
portion of the community that is very
risky averse
and that is kind of you know all these
this heterogeneity kind of mirrors the
practice of science that has evolved i
mean since we were both students right
um the science has become much more
collaborative even astrophysics and
cosmology that didn't used to be you
know run by collaborations hundreds of
people uh large
projects are now that it's become big
science it's transitioned to a big
science and i think with that comes a
certain kind of risk averseness because
you know you're asking for lots of
funding taxpayer money to do a project
it better be really well articulated it
it better you better find something it's
not going to be hit or miss you know
that's too much of a risk to take so i
think you know there are people who have
that sort of overall risk averse
mentality and then there are people like
me those are the flow
floating around not parts you know not
really
engaged totally with the big science
enterprise but wanting to take creative
risks and i think you know they would
think okay why not you know maybe this
is worth exploring and so on but you
know i think the thing that interests me
about the sociology of science is that i
bet you that
regardless of how
significant or insignificant this ggsl
tension is we don't know yet i mean we
just don't know we need a lot more
people to work on this
i i i can bet you that i am unlikely to
garner as much attention as adam and
company did for the hubble tension
partly because you know of course it has
to do with how pivotal the hubble
constant is and how it anchors so much
of this model and our view our cosmic
view is shaped by the hubble constant
right and its value and so on and
there's a long history of controversy
about it uh but i also think that you
know it you know this is something that
i often think about you know
who
and how
new ideas are proposed
matters and and i think that you know we
are in a field where you know the
playing field is not quite level yet
right um and i think that somebody like
adam reese who posed to nobel prize
found another sort of intriguing kind of
anomaly bringing you know the field to a
crisis point
makes a big difference i mean the fact
that he has a nobel prize to back him
you know makes everyone sit up and say
okay i think we should maybe look at it
a little more carefully a lot more
people will
um but you know on the other hand he got
the nobel prize because you know he was
able to resolve something that was
completely
you know crazy at the time right it was
believed to be so i think this idea of
how authority is conferred
and intellectual authority is conferred
and then
how a radical scientific idea gets to be
accepted it depends also obviously on
the content of the idea the significance
of the idea but i think you know who
proposes it which community it comes
from you know as you said gravitational
lensing should probably be more high
profile as an area but it's not
hopefully that'll change in the next
decade or two so some finding from that
field
uh could carry more water than um some
other fields so i think there are many
many factors you know it's it's a larger
sort of ecosystem
and this you know it's been very
interesting to watch um you know even in
a detached way before ggsl this how
these radical uh new ideas in our field
are accepted and you have experience of
that uh sean i mean you're extremely uh
creative original and take risks as well
right so you've not joined a thousand
person collaboration as their theorist i
would not be good at that but right but
you know the other thing i i like
everything you just said about you know
the
the
the humanness for for better for worse
you know when we're when we're in this
situation where
um
we don't yet know when there is an
anomaly a gap whatever you want to call
it there's a discrepancy between theory
and observation um science is at its
least objective in some sense in in
those cases but then the good news is
we're going to get more data right i
mean maybe this would be a good final
word like what will be the new data
coming in that will help us resolve this
kind of issue
yeah so i think um the the new data that
uh can really uh be a game changer in
this is you know deeper so at the moment
we have deep data in six clusters just
six
right
and so it would you know and you know
enlarging that sample of uh clusters for
which we have the depth of data from
hubble where you could do this kind of
analysis you could actually detect this
lenses within lenses i mean that's what
is sort of
uh needed but i think more than that you
know what you want is engagement you
want other people to get excited i mean
i think that's what i really want i mean
i would like many other people to get
excited to explore this further
and um and and see you know is there
something about the setting you know the
cluster that matters or whatever i think
attracting other intellectual capital
people their attention getting people
to work on this not attention and just
in terms of you know looking and
following it but actually engaging in
the work
and i think that would be awesome
absolutely
that's where we differ because i work so
slowly i don't want anyone else working
on the same areas that i am because
otherwise they will get every all the
good answers uh ahead of me but uh
looking forward to where your anomaly
goes and and what we learned more about
the universe so priyanka rajan thanks so
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thank you so much sean this was great
fun um i love your podcast series and
it's a real honor to be uh to be on it
we're very happy to have you thanks
[Music]
you